Okay Steve, so as in the past, can I introduce yourself?
My name is Steve Lawson, we're in a conference room in Valley Library on the 11th of November
2011.
So in our last session, we talked quite a bit about the Mayo Clinic controversy, and
I don't know what we need to go over the details of that again, but I'm interested in
knowing a little bit more about the response from what they needed to, especially if there
was a... there was ever a plan or an idea about developing a research program specifically
in response to the what the Mayo Clinic has said.
I don't think that there was a plan to develop a research project in response to the Mayo Clinic
studies.
Following in Cameron, and anyone else who was sympathetic to their position realized that
the studies purportedly done to replicate Cameron's work were very flawed, and as I mentioned
last time, Cameron and Paul and were angry that the New England Journal of Medicine, for instance,
did not publish critical letters in a timely fashion, and typically medical journals
will publish critical letters while the original clinical trial or study reported in that
journal.
It's still fresh in people's minds, and I think Paul and actually invoked his lawyer
to contact Arnold Realman of the New England Journal of Medicine to find out what had happened
to the letters that had been submitted, because the etiquette is that when you submit a publication
or a letter to a journal for consideration, for publication in that journal, you can't submit
it elsewhere.
So this kind of stymied the ability of Cameron and Pauling to air their grievances
about the Mayo Clinic studies in print in a journal, because they'd already submitted
really cogent responses and relevance him to be sitting on these for quite a long time.
I think finally they published something, but it was nearly a year after the original
study had been published, and letters are read, but they certainly don't attract the kind
of media interest that the original study attracted.
So I think Cameron and Pauling felt that they needed to continue on showing that vitamin
see had value, because they were both convinced by this time that vitamin see had value
for many cancer patients.
And Pauling was also becoming a little after the second Mayo Clinic trial.
He had heard from Abram Hoffer, the Canadian psychiatrist who had stimulated his interest
in B vitamins and schizophrenia back in the early 1960s, were mid 1960s that Hoffer had
been treating cancer patients with high dose vitamin C given orally, as well as an expanded
treatment regimen that included B vitamins, fatty acids, zinc, and some other micronutrients.
And these cancer patients seem to be doing quite well.
So Pauling encouraged Hoffer to collect that data with the intent of analyzing it and
then publishing it.
And they did that.
They published two papers in the journal of worth of molecular medicine on Hoffer's
observation.
So I think that this was not a response to the Mayo Clinic trials per se, but a continuation
of Pauling's deep interest in vitamin C and cancer.
And Hoffer has been, Hoffer is an MD PhD psychiatrist by training in profession.
And you might wonder why he was treating cancer patients.
Well, it turns out that many cancer patients, especially when given a diagnosis of prognosis
of terminal cancer, develop psychological problems, depression, anxiety, whatnot, and they
were being referred to Hoffer by oncologists in Vancouver and Victoria and British Columbia
to treat these mental manifestations that accompany the bad news about the cancer diagnosis.
So Hoffer began treating these people for mental health issues and kind of serendipitously
observed that they were living much longer in many cases than they were expected to live
by their oncologists.
And he brought that observation to Pauling and encouraged him than to collect the data.
So Cameron and Pauling continued to be very interested in vitamin C and cancer.
Cameron, I think, was a bit discouraged by the political implications of this whole
and brawlial at the Mayo Clinic, and I think he became very frustrated and discouraged.
And his attention was also turned elsewhere.
He was very interested in fatty acids and cancer and had set up a project at the Institute
to study the effect of oral fats in animals in a tumor model.
And he was also becoming more and more interested in AIDS.
In the potential value of high dose vitamin C in treating AIDS patients.
And as you know, he and Pauling worked on a book together that absorbed quite a lot of
Cameron's time and attention in those last years, which was never published.
Cameron, I believe, had known or new of David Horvins work in England.
And then Horvins had written a book on Omega-3 fatty acids.
He was a researcher and I believe he was also a clinician who was very interested in the
health sort of the orthomolecular approach to health using fatty acids and other micronutrients.
But he was particularly interested in fatty acids and brain function.
And Horvins, when I saw him at some point in the 1980s or early 1990s, had reported on a clinical trial,
preliminary clinical trial done in England with, I believe, schizophrenics who were given fatty
acid supplementation and MRIs or computer tomography had been done of their brains.
And they found that the ventricular spaces shrunk as a result of ingestion in these fatty acids
over a period of time, which also correlated with some symptomatic improvement.
So Horvins and Cameron, I think, too were become very interested in the psychiatric application of fatty acids.
And then, from epidemiological studies and rodent studies, it's been known for a long time that
Omega-6 fatty acids, polyensaturated fatty acids, may augment tumor development in some
rodent models. And there may be a protective effect by Omega-3 fats. So I think Cameron was
interested in teasing apart those effects of different types of fatty acids in a mouse model.
And that's an experiment that was set up at the Institute.
Yes. In 1986, how to live longer and feel better is published? Is this something that the
Omega-7 was part of at all, or is this entirely a calling project into himself?
Excuse me, Dorothy Monroe, of course, helped him with that because she was his secretary and
she worked a lot on that book. And I think he had helped perhaps from Fred Stitt, maybe some other
people at the Institute, but it wasn't an Institute wide effort. It was done by Linus Pauling.
I think so, a German probably helped him in getting references and things of that nature too.
But as far as I know, Pauling himself produced the draft. And I believe he shared that
probably with some people, including Fred Stitt, for proofreading and suggestions and so forth.
But I think it was largely his project. And he directed that the royalties from that book
come to the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine because he undertook the book as an
employee of the Linus Pauling Institute. It wasn't something he was doing on his own
for financial gain. He really wanted that money to come to the Institute to support research.
What sort of reaction did you know in response to the book of people that were getting a
whole of the Institute? Well, there seemed to be a lot of interest in the book.
The original hardcover was published by WH Freeman. That wasn't around long.
Then there was a paperback, also published by Freeman, that was a
what you call a trade paperback. It was larger than a regular pocketbook paperback.
And that seemed to sell very well in addition. And then shortly after the Freeman
editions, the mass market paperback rights were auctioned, and Avon was the successful bidder.
I think it was a best seller for Avon as well, and went through many, many, many
so people really responded to the book. I think it was in the New York Times best seller list
for a while. I'm not sure what the rank was or for how long, but it sold very, very well.
And I don't think that the main impact was financial revenue for the Institute to carry out research,
but more of an awareness of Pauling's ideas and orthomolecular medicine. In the fact that a lot of
this research was going on in California at the Linus Pauling Institute. So it definitely directed
attention to the Institute, but of course this was before the internet. So people reading the book
and wanting to learn more about the possible impact of vitamin C and other vitamins and nutritional
essential minerals and so forth on cognitive function or health prevention and treatment of cardiovascular
disease and cancer and so forth would typically call or write to the Institute. And that of course
resulted in a huge enterprise because we didn't have very many staff to deal with all these letters
that would come in. And you and Cameron who had been non-resident fellow in the Institute,
I think moved to California to take up position as medical director maybe around 1984, 1985,
somewhere in that mid-1980 period. And as I said earlier, a lot of his effort was directed at responding
to these letters and phone calls from people with medical problems who wanted to know about the
purative therapeutic value of micronutrients, especially vitamin C. Fred Stitt also helped in that
area quite a lot. Fred had joined the Institute as a volunteer in the early 1980s. He had known
Pauline at Caltech and was actually thanked in Pauline's book on the chemical bond,
nature of the chemical bond. So he and Pauline had had a long relationship. Fred was retired and
had an office at the Institute and Fred became the newsletter editor and also helped develop some
standardized information packets that the Institute could send out to people who had,
because at that point the volume of mail and requests was so large that oftentimes these things
couldn't be handled on a personal basis because there was just overwhelming. Some of the questions
were very peculiar or idiosyncratic and required a little bit of work to answer a little
research to find out what the appropriate response would be. Some other questions were a little
more generic in these information packets were designed and made to answer those more generic
questions. And Fred was heavily involved in that putting together these different generic packets
that could go out to people. So he vetted that mail for the most part. Fred and new in
Cameron and Dorothy Monroe. I think Carol Bastilleier had been doing this at Sandhill Road
Facility and I don't think that she was still part of the Institute in the 1980s when we moved to the
Page Mill Road Facility. But she had been doing a lot of that in Sandhill Road and actually
she'd identified quite a few issues. I think that were very important for people to think about,
especially with respect to liability trying not to provide medical advice, but being compassionate
and being helpful with people, but also not trying to tell them what to do medically because of course
we couldn't do anything like that. And Carol struggled with a lot of those issues and sort of
laid the groundwork for a successful strategy for answering these kinds of questions.
Yeah. Well, I think he enjoyed it. He definitely was interested in research, but he really
was a patient-oriented doctor and he would have been a terrific doctor to have for personal care
because he was very compassionate. He was a good listener and he was not at all afflicted by
the kind of arrogant or rushed attitude that you find in many contemporary physicians
just because the insurance reimbursement for physicians can be
conductate how medical practice is actually done in this country and doctors aren't allowed to
spend much time with patients. Cameron was not like that at all. He was much more old school
and really like to listen to people in their problems and then think about what the appropriate
treatment a response would be. So I think that responding to the public
who brought these health questions or concerns to the Institute, I think he enjoyed that.
So in 1987 we mentioned this a little bit already but the vitamin C and a AIDS research
starts to make it a little bit longer if you could describe what that research was.
Yeah, to the best of my recollection,
Rexie Gerrwell had come to the Institute from Johns Hopkins and I believe he knew
John Levitt at Johns Hopkins as well. John Levitt had joined the Institute to direct our molecular
carcinogenesis program which again really didn't have anything to do with orthomolecular medicine.
It was more looking at, as I said molecular carcinogenesis, how genes and certain proteins can
be involved in the development of the cancer phenotype. He was particularly interested in a mutant
beta act in which seemed to be a reliable marker for many types of human cancer and used
protein profiling extensively to do quantitative and qualitative studies of these gene products
that seemed to correlate with cancer. So Rexie was a virologist and he set up the laboratory
for viral carcinogenesis because his initial interest was in, set him a galo viral carcinogenesis
and carcinogenesis due to herpes virus type 2 infection because it was known at the time that
infection with HSV2 increased the risk for certain types of gynecologic cancers in women.
I'm not sure that it's related to any cancer increased cancer risk for men but there was an
increased cancer risk for women and I worked with him to some degree in that program we were looking
at small fragments of herpes virus type 2 DNA that were sufficient to cause transformation of
rat cells. So we would grow rat 2 cells which are quasi-normal cells in culture and then
transfect them with these small viral fragments from herpes virus type 2 and look to see if there
weren't any observable changes in these rat cells and we found the PST 2 or 3 C segment was sufficient
to cause the rat 2 cells to become overt tumor forming cells when injected into animals.
We also did a lot of protein profile. I had expertise in protein profiling at that time and
Raxeat really didn't so that was what I brought to his project and together we also worked
on a program that was supported by a philanthropist from Long Island, New York on fightic acid
which is found in seeds. It's an antioxidant that protects seeds from oxidation because seeds
need to store their genetic program very carefully and be free from oxidative damage while they're
waiting to germinate until the conditions are right for germination. So fightic acid plays a very
important role in protecting the seed genome and this fellow in New York had decided that it may
have some anti-cancer effects. So we were testing the anti-cancer effect of fightic acid in
Syrian hamster embryo cells and a number of other tumor cell lines. I was doing a lot of that
work, the cell culture worked and that generated a few papers including papers that showed that
fightic acids seem to affect cholesterol levels in animals and triglyceride levels in particular
and also could inhibit metal induced carcinogenesis in animals. We had a patent awarded for that
particular work. So Rexie was pretty well versed in cell culture and biology and carcinogenesis
and of course in the 1980s being close to San Francisco everyone was well aware of this new
syndrome that was primarily affecting male homosexuals although there seemed to be I think at that time
some incidents in hemophiliax too who were undergoing blood transfusions but the ideological agent
responsible for this age AIDS related. I can't remember exactly what the C stands for in that but
it was a syndrome that preceded over AIDS so people would of course wasn't known that HIV was
responsible for AIDS at that time. So there's a lot of concern about AIDS,
ARC and how infectious this disease might be and there were there was a lot of emphasis on things
like drug use and sex habits by male homosexuals that may contribute to immunodeficiency so
people weren't sure if it was a behavior, ideology or whether there was some kind of pathogen involved
and over time of course the 1980s it became clear from Monteniers' work in France and also
gallows work in the United States that aha there is actually an infectious agent here of virus
that's probably responsible for causing AIDS and then cells were available that were infected with
this virus HIV and we did and we're actually did a lot of work with Steve Harricke who was from
Lebanon, and Linus Pauling looking at the effect of vitamin C added to the culture medium
in which telymphocytes infected with HIV were grown so they wanted to find out whether
vitamin C would have any effect on viability of the virus or replication of the virus
and they found that it really affected viral replication very potently dramatically inhibited viral
replication and that was assayed by amounts of reverse transcriptase and also the formation of
Sincissia which are abnormal cells that are sort of pathologic correlates of telymphocytes infection
so that led to a paper that was published in PNAS with the three of them as authors I think Pauling
was a senior author in Gerroelle was perhaps the first author and that paper presented the results
of the cell culture experiments wasn't any clinical data but they suggested that this might
provide a promising approach for the treatment of AIDS namely by that time AZT had been
come available too for treatment of AIDS patients. AZT is pretty effective at inhibiting
the denoval infection of uninfected cells so you give AZD to patients and you preserve
those uninfected cells from becoming infected with the virus so vitamin C prevents viral
replication so the idea was that if you give AZT and vitamin C then you're inhibiting viral
replication and you're protecting if there is a little bit of viral replication you're also
inhibiting those new cells from becoming infected so the idea was that this might really
if it didn't eradicate the virus and kill the cells they were infected with the virus at least it
could could cause AIDS to become a manageable disease perhaps so yeah well are you carrying
involved well I think Cameron got involved because obviously there are medical issues involved
here and he was Gerroelle had a PhD but didn't have medical degree the only other person at
the Institute bit of veterinarian Roger Barth and Wolcott Dunham had an MD and Wolcott was doing
some work with guinea pigs and neurolatherism at the time but he was pretty advanced in age at
that time and was not physically very vigorous and Cameron was still very vigorous and of course
very interesting a lot of these issues and I think through conversation with Gerroelle and Paul
and Cameron just naturally gravitated to that especially once it had been demonstrated at vitamin C
might have an important role to play there. So what was the reaction to this
research both in the scientific community and in the public? Well I can't really say that I know
what the reaction was in the scientific community. I think by then maybe many people thought that
Linus Pauling was going to just publish great stuff about vitamin C no matter what and that you know
we'd never find anything coming from the Pauling Institute that had anything to do with a negative
effect of vitamin C just so happens that all these experiments were positive. So vitamin C's
not snake oil but it does have a lot of very important and interesting biochemical and physiological
functions in the body and protecting against and treating different diseases. So it's not a
panacea but it's really remarkable substance and it's easy to see while Linus Pauling gets so
interested in it early on. So I can't say what the what the professional reaction was I know that
there were AIDS there were doctors who treated AIDS patients who were very interested in our
results. In particular there were several physicians from San Francisco General at the AIDS
ward there who came down to the Institute and gave seminars and were in contact with Pauling
and Jeroelle about this and there was a lot of anecdotal evidence as well from San Francisco
in New York and other major urban centers and a lot of AIDS cases where some of the patients who
were self-medicating with high dose oral vitamin C seem to be doing a little bit better than
then their friends who were not taking high dose vitamin C but there weren't any controlled
clinical studies at that time and I don't think to date there had been any controlled clinical trials
on vitamin C and HIV infection or AIDS and of course the RCTs are most persuasive when it comes
to adopting new strategies in medicine. So absent RCTs I think probably a lot of physicians just
ignored it you know it's in the realm of anecdotal evidence it really doesn't mean anything it's
just coincidence yeah and vitamin C might have some value but it's such a pedestrian substance and I'm
sure that there are more promising biotherapies that we get involved in and you can't completely
disregard the political or financial perspectives in that whole debate either because a lot of
physicians who are charged with running clinical trials to evaluate drugs stand a benefit from
financially from from the revenue stream should that drug turn out to be effective so
a lot of people have tremendous incentive to study drug therapy and there's just not the same type
of incentive with vitamin C so but public reaction I think varied of course people who were
afflicted with AIDS or had friends who were afflicted with AIDS were quite interested
and very appreciative of the Institute's work other people who were a little bit
who felt for whatever moral reason that that AIDS was a behavioral disease and that we shouldn't
really waste money studying these problems that are due to behavior and if people would just
change their behavior wouldn't have to worry about this so some of those people with Drew support
and again as we saw after the negative male clinic studies on vitamin C and cancer there was
a lapse in some financial response to our direct male solicitation campaign but of course
that never influenced the work that we undertook I mean we undertook work that was
fundable either from grants or contracts or from unrestricted funds were available to us
and be quests for the direct male program but I can't ever recall any discussion that suggested
that any line of work at the Institute should be stopped because it was a negative effect on either
the you know how to the media where we're down we're we're nullifying it or
castigating it or donors were we're shining away because of that work so I think I think that kind of
emulates Pauling's courageous attribute and not backing down if you felt he was right and I think
the Institute sort of adopted that same strategy some important research to do and we're not
going to back down just because there's a loss of revenue you mentioned a Cameron and Pauling wrote
a book about the subject that was kind of published you know why that is a case shop in
my feeling is that they wrote the book without having talked any publisher and advanced to find out
first of all if there was any interest in the book so they had no publishing contract and secondly
I think the book was finished or nearly finished when Cameron became ill and I think his illness
probably led him to pay less attention to it or be less excited about it but I infer that I don't
know that for sure so we talked earlier about the vitamin C and cancer research and the perspective
from the in the Institute the staff being generally on board behind the thinking was of the
status in case the same with the vitamin C aid work as well I think so I mean I never talked to anybody
the Institute who expressed any squorn or negative feelings about that work I mean I think everybody
the Institute was relatively small and fairly collegial I mean there were certain tensions
and conflicts that developed over time of course from time to time as in any organization but I
think I think people were very respectful of one another when it came to the science like that
in 1989 Mathias Rat arrived at the Institute and I'm wondering if you could share your first
impressions of Rat yeah my first impressions were that he seemed like a very knowledgeable
earnest fellow he clearly had developed some exciting ideas with Linus Pauling and it was
great to see Linus Pauling and thused about the slip-up protein vitamin C story
so my initial reactions were quite favorable it wasn't until I became aware of some
other activities it seemed to be going on outside the purview of the Institute the Linus part
hard foundation and some other things which seemed to be a little obscure and not really conducted
in a transparent way that people began to question motivation in particular why are these other
organizations being set up what are they designed to do are they designed to compete with the
Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine this is a complementary activity and because a lot of
that kind of information wasn't forthcoming when you have kind of that black box it generates lots
of rumors and that's unfortunate and I think that there was certainly some of that going around
at the time although Linus Pauling also had been diagnosed with prostate cancer and Rat was providing
some medical services for Pauling himself and I think everybody appreciated that that here
was somebody at the Institute that Pauling was really interested in from a scientific standpoint
and was also looking out for Pauling's physical welfare so I think I think initially everybody was
quite enthused about this collaboration well I think initially he seemed to be very German
he didn't really seem to have a terribly great sense of humor it seemed to be very I won't
say solemn but very serious minded polite seem to treat people fairly there was some socializing
there was you know throughout the history of the Institute different employees and groups of
people would go out for dinners or lunch or go to bars on weekends or whatever and there was
there was some of that kind of activity as well what was his research program that
playing was excited about well Pauling of course had been long interested in vitamin C and cardiovascular
disease and he'd written about this in his book had a little longer feel better he'd also
written about it in articles for executive health which was a tabloid type newsletter he'd also
written about it for the Linus Plan Institute Science and Medicine newsletter in the 1970s and 1980s
primarily in the 1980s so he had a long abiding interest in the possible value of vitamin C
and preventing a treating heart disease rat had some specific interest in data on the potential
interaction between vitamin C and lipoprotein A which is a major constituent of atherosclerotic
plaque and also a risk factor for heart disease the problem with lipoprotein A is that it's
levels in the blood don't seem to be amenable to modification by dietary or even drug strategy
they're fairly they're genetically determined and they're very difficult to modulate
so there's a lot of skepticism is to where the vitamin C could actually affect lipoprotein A levels in blood
rat had apparently some a small set of clinical data that apparently showed that vitamin C
might have value in decreasing lipoprotein A levels and I think that was very interesting to Pauling
and then together they developed the hypothesis that lipoprotein A may serve as a surrogate for
vitamin C in animals including people that do not synthesize vitamin C and there are some
evidence that lipoprotein A levels in animals and people not synthesizing vitamin C were high
and lipoprotein A levels seem to be low in the blood of those animals that were synthesizing
vitamin C and that led them to think about well what is lipoprotein A doing
the vitamin C might otherwise do in the body and they believe that lipoprotein A might be synthesized
by the body to contend with and repair fissures that develop in the vascular church due to
oxidative damage or shear stress and other things of that nature so it might have a valuable role
in repairing lesions but that because it's a very sticky molecule it could
could end up developing into atherosclerotic plaque and from the original hypothesis there
were a number of correlaries that developed including the potential role of lysine in helping
to either decrease plaque or keelate and remove lipoprotein A from the blood and Pauling
published in the Journal of Worth Molecular Medicine in the early 1990s three case reports
of people who had suffered from severe angina exercise induced angina who had had
very serious cardiovascular disease bypass and other surgical interventions and still had
angina and they read Pauling's papers with RAF and decided to try adding lysine to their
regimen and in some cases these people had already been taking fairly high doses of vitamin C
and then added lysine. They weren't controlled studies so these were reported as anecdotes
in the amount of lysine in vitamin C was quite variable but it was on the order of three to six
grams per day of each and they reported fairly rapid relief from angina so Pauling speculated that
perhaps because the relief was so rapid that lysine might even buy into lipoprotein A in plaque
and help remove it from plaque and that was possibly explaining why these people were not
suffering from angina because the plaque was the thickness of the plaque was decreasing.
Well it turns out subsequent research has revealed that vitamin C has very important effects
in vasodilation in sort of improving blood flow in people with atherosclerotic plaque
through its effects on tetrahedrobiopterin which is involved in synthesis of nitric oxide which
improves blood flow but the role of lysine in this process is still obscure and I don't think
other than Pauling's hypothesis I don't think there's been much speculation as to why lysine
in particular might have had this benefit because as I mentioned some of the people that were
reported in these case studies had already been taking very high dose vitamin C without
presumably any benefit yet when they added lysine there seemed to be a fairly dramatic effect
so that I thought was a very it's an interesting area and probably a rich area for research
although as far as I know no one's really looked into it. So those were some of the ideas that
Pauling and Wrath were developing in that that period that I think were exciting to everybody and
as I as I came to understand the Linus Point Heart Foundation was specifically set up
to raise money to support clinical trials on some of these potential therapies including
Proline, lysine, vitamin C, niacin, and so forth.
We'll talk more about Wrath here in a second. There's a couple of things that happen sort of
chronologically that I want to touch on first in 1990. There was a reason effort in Paloco
which I have the city gave the Institute three years to move basically. All right. What was the
reaction of that and how did you start applying for that? Well that was very interesting. That was about
the same time that Emil Zootke-Kandel and Rick Hicks retired from the Linus Point Heart Foundation
to Science and Medicine and set up the Institute for Molecular Medical Sciences and we least
them space within the facility at 440 page Mel Road to do that. So that was a very contentious
time. Emil and Rick Hicks left the Institute. Emil still had strong interest in preserving
a research program and yet didn't have a lot of funding available to him. So Pauling wanted us to find
out whether or not us meaning Stephen Maddox myself and Zee Kerman to find out whether this was
practical and feasible to subbly space in Linus Point, Jr. is involved in that as well. To
subly space to IMMS within the building and how the building might be partitioned and how equipment
might be made available to IMMS or how they could share equipment and so on and so forth. So that was
kind of a contentious time at the Institute but resulted in a sub least IMMS because we found
a way to make everything work to everyone satisfaction. And at about that time I had become executive
officer of the Institute and was working very closely with Linus Pauling Jr. Because Linus Pauling
Senior was undergoing treatment for cancer and still had problems in structural chemistry
and theoretical chemistry and and orthomolic in the medicine that he really wanted to devote his
time to. So Linus Pauling Jr. in the board decided to free his father from administrator
responsibilities and Linus Point Jr. would sort of step in as president or director of the
Institute and I would assist him and initially I was asked by Linus Pauling to assist him and then later
when it became clear that he wasn't really interested in exercising any administrator
responsibility Linus Pauling Jr. stepped in and then I worked very closely with Linus Pauling Jr.
And that was my first understanding of the fact that the Institute had the zoning problem
and apparently it had been known for a long time but nobody had really done much about it.
So Linus Pauling Jr. and I and the board realized that absent and endowment and a lot of money
it was really going to be difficult for us to sustain the Institute as a viable biomedical
research organization if we had to move because we had a very favorable
leasing arrangement with our landlords, the cost of the lease went up only adjusted by CPI, the consumer
price index. So we were paying I think 50 or 55 cents a square foot for 20,000 plus square foot building
in Palo Alto and to move we would have been looking at probably 5, 6, 7, 8, 10, 12 dollars
of square foot. So the prospect of moving was not very satisfying because it meant that we would
be spending much more money on just simply renting the facility and not have much money available
to pay staff, recruit or do research. So that was not an appealing option at all.
Yet we were suddenly aware that we had three years when we really had to leave because the
master plan in Palo Alto called for changing the mix of commercial and residential properties
because they were becoming very concerned that there weren't enough residential units for people
that worked in Palo Alto and it's kind of a I don't want to go off on a tangent but I had long
discussions with city planners, city staff, the planning committee for Palo Alto and some of the
council members and my opinion at the time was well that's fine. You can build condominiums or
apartment buildings here but there's no way you can ensure that the people who rent or buy these
condos or apartment buildings are going to work in Palo Alto because Palo Alto has a very desirable
address. People might move here and work in Sunnyvale or San Francisco or Hayward or these Bay
or the South Bay and you're just going to increase traffic and it's going to become not necessarily
the outcome that you're striving for with this zoning change but be that as it may we really had to
face the inevitable which was the zoning was going to change and so I decided that it was imperative
to delay that until we could really come up with a proper solution for for the Institute's future
and taking a page out of line as Paul and Eva Helen's book we set up folding tables around town
outside grocery stores and cafes and had petitions and I can't remember the exact wording of the
petition but it was something to the effect please sign the petition if you'd like to see the
Institute stay at its location in Palo Alto if you feel that we're doing good work and so on and so forth
we had quite a few names sign in those petitions and they were eventually delivered to the
City Council and I made a presentation in the City Council. One is Paul made a presentation in the
City Council and eventually we squeak through with City Council approval to delay that zoning
change for a period of time because they recognized that we were doing valuable work and that we
really needed more time to chart a proper course for the future and it's one of the Palo Alto
City Council members mentioned she didn't want to read the New York Times that the city of Palo Alto
had kicked the line as Paul and Institute out of town. Yeah so that was a very successful campaign
and I should mention that during the City Council meeting appearances I felt well it's
good and fine for me to go and talk to the City Council and I'd met all of the City Council
members individually and pleaded our case to them and they seemed to be favorably disposed to the
Institute although some of them were wavering somewhat and I figured that I could make a pretty
compelling argument in front of the City Council during public testimony but I thought it would
really accentuate if line is Pauling himself could appear and I asked him if he would be willing to
do that and he said yes so he went with me to the City Council meeting and it just so happened
that that meeting of the City Council where they were scheduled to vote on this issue was the first
appearance by Geahart Casper who was president of the Stanford University and there was a tradition
where the president of the university would go and make I think on an annual basis of state of the
University address to the City Council because Stanford is adjacent to the City of Palo Alto and
they have a lot of mutual interests and mutual conflicts so they're they're very the city is always
interested in finding out what Stanford's doing and Stanford's always interested in finding out
what the city is planning so Geahart Casper was there to to spend 20 minutes or so giving his
address to the City Council and as Pauling walked in and the chambers were full of people who were
waiting to give testimony Geahart Casper recognized Pauling and ran over to him and the two of them
exchange pleasentries they'd never met before and Geahart Casper who I believe was scheduled before
me or before Pauling on the agenda spent quite a lot of his a lot of time talking about what a
wonderful person Linus Pauling was talked about at Stanford there are many Nobel Prize winners there
are so many that they really don't turn heads anymore except for Linus Pauling because Linus Pauling
was such an outstanding scholar and such an outstanding piece activist and scientists that when
Pauling was there heads did turn and I thought it was quite nice of Casper to talk about Pauling
and those glowing terms in Casper is a lawyer so he didn't really have professionally much
exposure to Linus Pauling's work in science but nevertheless he recognized that Pauling was
a really eminent scientist and really wanted to pay tribute to him so that kind of cinch the case for
as I think and also there was a fellow in the audience who stood up and introduced himself by name
and said that he felt Pauling's work was very important and the institutes work was very important
and really wanted to encourage the city council to delay the zoning change and at the end of the meeting
when we were waiting I was with Pauling and the underground garage waiting for the card to come
around and Pauling mentioned to me that he remembered that fellow who gave public testimony
he was a student of his a Caltech and he remembered an incident with him and said that when he was teaching
he had he had the secretic method of teaching where he would pick out people to answer questions
because the classes were apparently small enough he knew whole the students were new their
excuse me knew their names so during one of his chemistry lectures he had a
question and he picked this fellow out to answer the question and the fellow proceeded to
given answer there was really not the right answer but I guess he felt compelled to say something
so Pauling just nodded and thanked him for the response and at the end of the class Pauling went
up to him and said I'd like to talk with you for a moment and Pauling said you know it's perfectly
okay when you don't know the answer to a question to admit that and so you don't know the answer
actually it's far better than confabulating but I thought it was it was rather amazing that Pauling
remembered that particular incident and this particular fellow who I'm sure he hadn't thought
about or seen for decades yeah back track real quick I was interested to do that when
Zucacondal and Hicks were good friends and allies and they'd worked very very closely together
and had actually sacrificed a lot for the Institute a meal had loaned the Institute money gone
without salary or decrease salary and and Rick Hicks had been also very self-sacrificing
trying to help the Institute progress over the years so I think I think Rick felt when a
meal's contract was not renewed that he would leave as well and so both of them left but Hicks
was then voted to join the Board of Trustees of the Lions Plains 2 Science and Medicine which I
thought was a terrific collegial and important move for the Board of Trustees to make because Hicks had
a lot of insight into fundraising for the Institute and a lot just a lot of knowledge and insight
about the Institute in general and I thought that would be very important for him to to be associated
in a continued way with the Institute so I thought that was a very good strategic move to ask Rick
to become part of the Board and a meal of course had his hands full of trying to administer and get
his new Institute Institute of Molecular Medical Sciences off the ground and a meal had actually
wanted me as well as a number of other people Jim Fleming and Greg Spicer, Teddy Bullockos and
other people who were doing more molecular biological work that was not really directly allied with
orthomolecular medicine. For instance Greg Spicer was doing work in molecular evolution.
Jim Fleming was doing work in molecular basis of aging. Teddy Bullockos was working on
histones and DNA repair and a lot of those programs didn't really fit into the
orthomolecular scope of the Institute and when the Institute was reorganized when Hicks and Zucaconda
left the Board decided to refocus the limited resources on orthomolecular medicine so they wanted
to have a much more narrow focus and kind of pair away some of those programs that were not
closely allied with that mission because we just could not afford to do everything and those
programs that were being paired away a meal hoped to collect in this new organization
Institute of Molecular Medical Sciences and he did to some extent. Did that pre-successfully?
So this the version sent in the research engine that was the primary reason first of the
gross departure from the Institute. Do what? The reason that the divergence in the research
of dentist was his primary reason believing? Yeah when understanding was that the Board was very
concerned about income and outgo. So the Board had become increasingly concerned over the late 1980s
about the cost of all the programs at the Institute and the variable fundraising success.
The Cessacawa donation $500,000 a year for 10 years was coming to an end and couldn't be renewed
due to their charter stipulations. So it was difficult to find money to support some of this work
that was not grant funded and a lot of it was not grant funded. The years of yurka had a nice grant
from the Department of Energy that was funding his work on all those sequences and non-conserved
and concerned DNA and so forth. But a meals program that I was involved in looking at metastatic
cancer, Greg Spicer's work, some of the other work was really not funded except through
unrestricted funds to the Institute. So the Board decided to ask a meal to shrink the Institute
so that the expenses would be more aligned with the actual revenue instead of continuing to grow
the Institute or allowing it to continue at what they considered an infeasable size. And I think
a meal was didn't want to do that. So rather than do something that he didn't want to do,
I think he resigned and with him went with a kick. We talked about Cameron's illness and in 1991 he died.
I'm warning if he treated himself at all with some of the techniques that he'd been advocating for
you know. Yeah, that's very interesting. I had asked Cameron about his own habits with vitamin C
supplementation much earlier before he became sick and he said that he was taking a little vitamin
C but not taking mega doses because he thought that you know, should he ever get ill that he
wanted to reserve those mega doses for therapeutic value. I think he probably took some vitamin C
but as far as I know he never himself took intravenous vitamin C and again the differential
response to people getting intravenous vitamin C and oral vitamin C was not well characterized at that
time. It was clear that some of the patients getting IV vitamin C did very well. But also,
if you go back and look at the historical record, Cameron's patient pool, some of those early
patients that had complete necrosis of tumors got only oral vitamin C and the tumor necrosis
was a consequence temporally of that high dose oral vitamin C. So I think Cameron and others
believe that oral vitamin C had some anti cancer effects as well. Although much later, of course,
these transport molecules for vitamin C were discovered and this was after Cameron and Pauling
it both died. These discoveries were made. So now we have a better understanding of
the limitations of achieving high concentration of vitamin C and the blood when you take it only
early but in those days that wasn't well known. So Cameron may have felt and I never talked
him about this but he may have felt that since some of his patients did quite well apparently
on oral vitamin C that may be intravenous vitamin C was not important for him. But he also,
at the end of his illness, became less willing to see friends in colleagues.
So there were many occasions when Zelecurman and Zelec's girlfriend and I would go to
Connie Cameron's house in Redwood City and UN was not well enough to see visitors. So we would
sit and chat with Connie Cameron and offer her solace and ask her to pass on our good wishes to
you and but he clearly was not feeling well enough to see visitors.
What was the impact of the homie institute?
Well, UN was such a charismatic and wonderful man that it really had had a big impact on people personally.
I recall his memorial service in Redwood City. Zelec girlfriends,
Zelecurman's girlfriend played bagpipes and it was just an incredibly emotional of that.
People were really grieving about Cameron's death and of course Pauling was there and
rat was there as well. Everybody felt terrible about Cameron's death.
In 1992 the case rat was appointed vice president for financial affairs at the Institute of
this. That's a good question. That was 1992. You said? Yeah.
This was after Cameron's death. So Cameron was probably Pauling's closest collaborator
in Zelecurman of course as well. When rat arrived with these ideas about cardiovascular disease
and the propotein and vitamin C and he and Pauling started working very closely on this collaboration.
I think that sort of took center stage in Pauling's life and although he remained committed
to some of the problems that he was working with Zelecurman, I think his bond with rat
was getting stronger and stronger. I think Pauling may have unilaterally made that decision
to give that appointment to rat because he had no reason not to trust him. And clearly,
I think Pauling and rat perceived perhaps a new focus for research in the Institute which would
be vitamin C and art disease especially now that there was this reinvigeration of this
focus on orthomolecular medicine. So I think that perhaps it seemed logical that rat would be involved
there because they also had set up the heart foundation and other organizations to try to raise
money specifically for these clinical trials. So how do things start to unravel them?
Well, I think rat did a number of things that upset Pauling and caused some
consternation that was kind of a political strategy in a scientific realm which sometimes can
work and sometimes can backfire. And I remember there was one meeting I believe in Texas.
I can't remember the specific society but it was cardiovascular disease,
researchers and physicians and rat had zerox something and put it on every seat in the auditorium
for everybody to read and rat was also developing these ideas about big pharma trying to suppress
or inhibit work on orthomolecular medicine. And I think a lot of people share those
opinions to some degree. And rat just seemed to be using more of a political strategy to advance
the research agenda. And some of those things were done I think Pauling felt and others felt
maybe not an entirely appropriate manner. I remember seeing one press release that rat had written
and Pauling had written all over it that it was really unwise and uncalled for had nothing new to
announce. And I think Linus Pauling was starting to worry a little bit about the trust that he placed
in rat. So at some point when that fundraiser or executive vice president position was
I think graph resigned or that position was eliminated. Steven Maddox became Vice President for
Finance or Fundraising or whatever the particular title was. So he sort of succeeded
Rick Hicks after an interlude there with Matthias Raffping in that position for a while.
And Linus Pauling Jr. and I became increasingly concerned about
Raff and his activities. And we also became aware of the fact that Raff had not signed the patent agreement
and it was incumbent upon every employee as an obligation of employment to sign a patent agreement.
And the patent agreement was actually quite generous when people joined corporations as employees
they typically surrender. All their rights to the company. And many people can invent and discover
wonderful things for companies and not see a dime. Academic institutions attend a little bit
differently in our organization, which was modeled after an academic institution. It was fairly
generous to inventors. So the idea was that if you discover something that may be patentable in the
course of your employment at the Institute, you can bring that to the Institute's administration
in the decision we had a patent committee at the time and a decision can be made as to whether the
Institute would like to pursue this file to get the initiate the patent application process
or if the Institute did not want to pursue it then they would surrender it to you and you could
pursue it at your own expense and you would have the patent and you could go ahead and license it
and if there was a revenue stream that would be solely yours. So the patent agreement stipulated
should the Institute proceed to try to gain a patent for this invention or discovery
that should it be licensed the revenue would be split between the inventor and the Institute
and the following percentages. And everybody had signed that. Linus Pauling had signed that himself
and Wrath refused to sign it. I think initially he said he would like to think about it and I think
the choice was given to him well you know you really obligated as an employee to sign this and if you
don't want to sign it then you know perhaps you should think about resigning. So he asked for some
time to think about that and said fine and a day or two later he said that he wanted to quit
and wanted to resign and he did. What was the source of the litigation that he filed
against the Institute kind of that the right? Well he resigned and I really had no interest to or
I mean I mean I had my hands full of trying to solve a lot of the financial and personnel
and research problems at the Institute and think about where the Institute should go in the future
and Linus Pauling's health and all these other myriad problems that we were facing so I really didn't
keep up with what Wrath was doing because he resigned from the Institute he was gone. I didn't really
honestly care about what he was doing and it wasn't until maybe a year or so later that we were
served with a lawsuit and he had set up a company called Health Now Incorporated and this company
was suing Linus Pauling and the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine for interference with
its business activities and the gist of the suit was that Wrath apparently had been trying to get
to forge business relationships with supplement companies and he was bringing to them these
ideas about vitamin C and heart disease and lysine and so forth presumably to formulate new
products or whatever and according to the suit he had met with discouragement from some of these
company representatives because they didn't know who he was and they would point to new stories
about Linus Pauling and vitamin C and cardiovascular disease or heart health and in many of those
stories Wrath's name was omitted not because Pauling failed to give him credit because Pauling I think
was very fair and egalitarian about that and would always mention Wrath when he talked to journalists
or media about these ideas and lipoprotein A and vitamin C and heart disease authors
clorosis but because Wrath was kind of an unknown quantity and really had no reputation to speak of
and I'm just inferring this media often would drop his name and the focus would be on Linus Pauling
and I think Wrath found that very frustrating and discouraging because he perceived that
that lack of credit interfering with his ability to to make these business relationships with
different supplement companies and so he found an attorney and decided to file suit against the
institute and that led to actually his complaint was dismissed essentially but we thought the
cross complaint because in the course of this litigation he had made a lot of statements that we
thought were injurious to our activities. At the time we were trying to forge a relationship with
Elizabeth Arden and Unilever Corporation who were interested in developing a line of
cosmetic products that would include things like vitamin C and antioxidants and phytochemicals
and they wanted to support some research at the Institute and get involved with the Institute
and interesting ways and Wrath had started to communicate with these people telling them that we were
unreliable business partners and so on and so forth and that he owned all these rights and
so we we felt compelled to sue him to stop interfering with our business relationships
and during the course of this litigation Wrath alluded to some agreements that he had
executed with Linus Pauling that he claimed gave him all kinds of rights that we weren't aware of.
So Linus Pauling Jr and I were we're bewildered by this and we went to the documents that
Dorothy Monroe pulled out of a file for us and she showed us these agreements that
look like had been written by Wrath and signed by Pauling and then in some cases witnessed by a third
party and they had to do with Wrath's rights essentially and we were very surprised by these documents
they didn't seem to be proper and we took them to Linus Pauling and showed them to him and asked
him if he had any memory of these documents or the circumstances under which he signed them
and he looked at them very carefully and was confused about them and said red them and said
well that certainly looks like my name I believe that that's my signature but I don't recall
the content of this document at all and now that I read it I would not have signed it so we tried to
reconstruct why Linus Pauling signed these documents and we came to the impression and again
it's hard to verify this independently I can't be verified independently but based on statements
that Dorothy Monroe and others made we came to the opinion that Wrath had gotten Pauling to sign
these documents when he was executive vice president and may have gone into Pauling's office with
a whole sheath of documents for Pauling to execute and these documents were probably among those papers
and Pauling just signed them without reading them carefully and it turned out in the consequence
of litigation the documents that Pauling had signed giving Wrath lots of rights and ownership
were nullified for lack of compensation so how is all of the litigation ago
well litigation when was resolved you know typically the court really encourages you to come to a
settlement and there are settlement conferences set up by the court to get the parties together
to hash out a settlement because the court really doesn't want to get involved in litigation unless
it's absolutely necessary so they have retired judges who mediate these settlement conferences and
the retired judge seems to have the strategy of keeping people in a room until they give up
where dad and settle and it's a strategy I think that works pretty often so we had a number of
settlement conferences and eventually rather than going through a trial Wrath sued against us
had been dismissed so the only remaining issue was our suit against him across complaint
excuse me for libel and judicious inferences called interference where their business
relationship I can't remember the exact terminology so that was what was on the table to settle
the suit against health now and Wrath so we came to a settlement that we were satisfied with we
Wrath was supposed to pay us at least $75,000 we were not to disparage his activities he
would not disparage our activities mutual non disparagement and we assigned him some patents that
he basically had had done the work on so we felt you know we'd be fine to give him those patents
we didn't really expect them to generate any income anyway and that was the the just of the settlement
by and large and Wrath never paid the $75,000 so we mentioned a little bit of the course of this interview
the role that line is pointing you played and essentially inserting himself and dealing with
somebody administrative issues that his father was utter disinterested or unable to do because of
advancing age in the client health I'm wondering if you could comment a little bit on sort of last
years arrival at the Institute in the role that he played in those last years of his father's life
yeah well when the the staff became aware of the fact that there were problems or financial
problems so this was you know sometime in the very early 1990s and then when Pauling had been diagnosed
and disclosed his disease publicly there was quite a lot of anxiety I would say because people
really weren't sure what was going to happen to them to the research programs to the Institute
and there was just a lot of unease among the staff and the board I think recognized this and
realized that they had to do something specific and concrete and make some very definite steps
and kind of clarify all the ambiguity and gossip that was going around and kind of put it into the
gossip and really lay things out here's where the status is now and here's where we're going to
future and Linus Plan Jr had been a board member right from the the early days at the Institute
but I think he recognized that his father was unwilling or unable to resolve some of these issues
in a really meaningful way so he decided to assert himself more in the role of the board so he decided
or I guess with the board and his father's acknowledgement he became chairman of the board of trustees
and Linus Pauling became director of research I think at that time too so because Pauling was
essentially directing a lot of the research at the Institute anyway so he was director of research
Linus Plan Jr I believe became chairman of the board and then at some point in there I moved from
becoming executive officer to chief executive officer and because Linus Pauling Jr was chairman of the board
and we had lots of problems and I had very little experience in large scale administration I'd been
administering a relatively small research group with a little bit of fundraising activity and a
little bit of public relations I frequently gave tours to the two people who visited the
Institute and wanted to learn about our science so I had some skills there I guess or some
experience at least and Linus Plan Jr and I started to work very closely together so I had really
I had seen him before but I had never really worked intensively with him until he sort of took over
management for his father in those early days nearly part of the decade there and I found him to be
very a very reasonable, forceful, thoughtful person and I really appreciated his skill and essentially
wisdom in addressing some of these issues that faced the Institute he seemed to have a pretty
pretty good way of analyzing some of the problems and together we worked up strategies to
to solve some of the issues that we were facing. Was it all intentional for them to be instituted
through the rival and the assumption of his role? I don't think so because I think most people
realized that Linus Plan was not going to be an effective administrator of the Institute at that stage
so somebody needed to take put their hand on the rudder of the ship and start to exercise some
direction and I think people were I mean I can't say what everybody's reaction was about me
becoming chief executive officer because that was an unusual move. I didn't have an advanced degree
although I had been co-directing a relatively small research group and there were other people
with seniority that one could have predicted would have been asked to become chief executive officer.
I'm not quite sure why I was asked but I was honestly I was a little flattered and I thought
I felt very stimulated by the challenge of becoming chief executive officer learning more about
what problems the Institute faced and how to solve them because I always considered myself a
bit of a problem solver and here was a whole set of what seemed to be very, very serious problem so
I'm not sure I would have taken the job and you know if I'd known when they asked me
to become CEO the magnitude of the problems that the Institute faced but I'm glad I did.
What was the biggest challenge in hindsight for you as doing that role?
Well the biggest problem the biggest immediate problem was funding and it was heartbreaking for me
to lay off people that I had worked with and for for a very, very long time absolutely heartbreaking.
I mean I literally had tears as when I was telling people that there was no longer job for
them at the Institute but it was a fact of life and it was sort of my first first exposure to
what it's like to be in charge and make unpopular decisions or decisions that you don't want to
make as a person but you're obligated to make because of the role that you're playing in an
organization so it was it was difficult too. A couple more questions for today one event in the
Institute that seemed to come at exactly the right time was it the donation of the state of
Carl Spontner. Yes yes you give any background on this this is something that seems to
provide a bit of a lifeline to the Institute that most needed it. That's right and it's
a matter of fact I remarked to a meal because a meal had already decided that that time that he was
leaving that was kind of a bittersweet news for a meal because on the one hand you know this was
the salvation financial salvation for the Institute but other decisions that already been made
so it came a little too late in some regard swadner to the best of my understanding had been a
a donor to the Institute for quite a long time very small amounts of money and at the time
the Institute did not have access to a lot of research capability to investigate donors based on
tax filings or real estate holdings or zip code or anything like that. These days it's very sophisticated
kind of donor research that philanthropic organizations or foundations can do to find out
really who among their constituents have the ability to to make large gifts of one sort or another
back then we didn't really have that ability so there was no way of targeting people who were
giving small donations to the Institute for cultivation for instance and the other kinds of
fundraising strategies that might be developed to encourage people to give money so as a big surprise
when we were notified about this estate that had lots of different aspects to it I believe there was
an office building at home and gold coins and money and just a lot of different financial instruments
within this estate and it really did allow us to pay off some of the debts to trustees who had
loaned the Institute money and to kind of get on an even keel a bit and we also within a a
couple years became aware of another big request the Phineastate which also helped us
establish enough money so that we could have an endowment that would make the Institute more attractive
to a college or university to which we might move and it allowed us to bring $1.5 million
at least to Oregon State University when we moved up here in 1996 to endow the director's position
and at that time there was a match in the state so there was a functional $3 million
endowment which was really a good endowment to attract top caliber scientists for this
director ship at the Linus Pong Institute but getting back to the Phineastate.
The Phineastate was sometime in the early 1990s maybe 93 through 94 or 5 I don't really remember
the exact date at that time I was also negotiating contracts with Elizabeth Arden that I expected
would produce a very considerable revenue stream for the Institute for a very conceivably quite a long
time and that to me look like it might be the Salvation Financial Salvation for the Institute
and allow the Institute to remain as an independent biomedical organization and recruit
a track top caliber scientists but that was still under negotiation and under development we
weren't quite sure where that was going to go. I got a phone call from a woman in New Jersey I believe
who said that she wanted to know if I was aware of, the beginning was Katherine Finney,
Katherine Finney and not quite sure what her first name was but this woman had been her best friend
and was aware of the last will and testament and told me that she herself had been named
as the beneficiary in the will and was to receive a condominium and the Institute was to receive
most of the financial instruments that were available in the estate and then I think there was
small donations elsewhere but it was a fairly large amount of money and several million dollars
and the woman told me that Finney had been deteriorating in recent months and a caregiver had
come to live with her and this caregiver apparently had persuaded Finney to alter her will
and leave everything to him and the woman who called me thought that this was really
unethical and unjust and that this person had exploited deteriorating woman to his own financial gain
and it sure seemed that way to me I mean I didn't know what the facts of the case were but I hired
a firm in New Jersey to look into it and it resulted in a nice settlement for the Institute where
we got the belief several million dollars, the caretaker ended up with several hundred thousand
dollars and the woman who brought this to our attention ended up with her condominium.
What happened to the Elizabeth Arden relationship?
Elizabeth Arden relationship was quite promising I was really excited by that because there was
a research element too that they were quite interested in funding research that would
find out if vitamin C and other micronutrients or phytochemicals could protect skin cells,
caretinasites from damage by sun exposure because they were starting to develop cosmetic
topical cosmetic products that included these micronutrients and they also had some
preliminary data from their own labs that suggested that topical application of vitamin C and
other substances improved the appearance of the skin and I think from from a marketing standpoint
they were excited about getting involved with the Institute because as the director of research told
me their facility was in trouble Connecticut he's the one who really got in contact with us
and asked us if we were interested in working with them in this regard he said you know he
started thinking about vitamin C well who who really knows the most about vitamin C and as well
it's Linus Paul and I should contact the Linus Paul Institute and he did and we decided because
the prospect of revenue was so great or the prospect of a lot of revenue was so great that
wasn't something that we should just take lightly or dismiss so we spent a lot of time thinking
about this and analyzing it and we were in some of the trustees were concerned about the
commercial exploitation of the name Linus Pauling and they thought you know perhaps if
this product bombs and were associated with it that maybe it will tarnish our reputation
but we worked out an agreement where we had review of all the marketing literature that
ardent and unilever would produce and they could make certain factual statements about what they were
doing at the Institute supporting a research project and so forth and that we were not engaged
in researching development with ardent looking to formulate new products with ardent and that
wasn't something that was part of this arrangement or relationship and then we agreed to produce
a joint newsletter that would be translated into many different languages and available at
point of sale in high end department stores around the world and we did that one newsletter
which featured an interview with Linus Pauling. Lester Packer also had an article in that
and some information about the Institute because I saw this as a way of expanding
our base of constituents because if we could introduce the Institute and its activities
to younger people or middle-aged people that shop at these high end department stores
presumably they have high income that they might get interested in supporting the Institute's
research and may at some point you know in the distant future decide to give us
requests as well if they thought the work we were doing was was good so I thought this I thought this
was a good way to expand the Institute's influence get more public education about what we were
doing and generate revenue for the Institute and in addition to that exposure there was also a
financial element where we would gain financially from the sale of some of their products and this
looked to be remarkably large magnitude of money for us really staggering amount of money possibly
and everything was great I went to Humber, Germany and to New York City and Toronto participated
in press conferences the marketing materials were all developed the product line was about to be launched
and the president of Elizabeth Arden Bob Phillips at the time left Arden to take a job with
Unilever in London which is the parent company of Elizabeth Arden and they hired a new president
from Chicago and this new president came in and proceeded to turn the company upside down
suspended a lot of the research contracts except for ours suspended a lot of the marketing efforts for
new products and things like that so unfortunately although everything everybody had expectations for
great success because of this management change at Arden it really interfered with the role out of all these
products and marketing strategies and everything else and she was she left the company after a year
and it took them a couple of years after that to fully recover so needless to say our high hopes
were somewhat dashed there because of management issues that Elizabeth Arden and they never followed
one of the many years afterwards they may have you know I don't really follow the cosmetics industry
so I don't know what they did subsequently but the relationship with the Institute eventually came
to an end they continued to provide money you know because we had a contract we had a contract
with Elizabeth Arden and we had a sub license from LC Progeny to use the name Linus Pauling and
so we could use that name in our association or contractual association with Elizabeth Arden and they
were funding a research project as I mentioned that was transferred to LPI at Oregon State so
the funding continued for some time and then eventually that project funding ran out and then that was
the end of the relationship but they also underwrote our newsletter and they provided
I was talking to John McCook who was the vice president for research at Arden and
after Pauling's death I brought up with him the prospect of doing a very nice commemorative issue
of the newsletter that would pay tribute specifically to Linus Pauling and he thought that was terrific
idea and we didn't have the money to produce anything really nice ourselves high volume so Arden
very graciously underwrote the commemorative booklet that we produced in lieu of a fall newsletter
in 1994 after Linus Pauling died. So the last question for today is August of 94 Linus Pauling
dies how would you characterize the state of the Institute at the point? Well it was a terrible day
I mean it was a day that we knew was inevitable but you never want to get that news even
when you know you should be expecting it. It was a summer day a beautiful day in Palo Alto
Pauling had been at his ranch in Big Sur and so a permanent eye and some other people had been
down to see him there was a deposition actually of Pauling I believe earlier that summer by our
attorneys that we went down for but I didn't have any direct knowledge of his deterioration or
or health status I knew that he wasn't doing really well but I didn't really have any first-hand
knowledge of what he was doing there so we had worked up in a bituary based on information available
to us from his biography and from Paradowski's work and probably from materials that were available
to us from special collections so we had an obituary ready to go and of course this was as I said before
the internet so the obituary was to be fact upon notification of Pauling's death so it had been a
typically difficult day at the Institute for me it was always challenging in those days with litigation
and financial problems and thinking about the future just position of the Institute and so forth and
I remember going home that day in August and I had a couple of beers before dinner and I got
a call from Linus Pond Jr before I had a chance to eat and Linus Pond Jr told me that it's father
had just died and it really hit me hard because I was kind of surprised at my own emotional reaction
because I really loved Linus Pond he was just an amazing person so immediately I got back to my
car I went back to the Institute and I started faxing these obituraries which I had a stack of obituraries
with media contact numbers so they went to CBS, New York Times, NBC, excuse me see and then
whatever the media context we had I'd sent that them out San Francisco Chronicles and as a
mercury they were probably 15 or 20 of these to be faxed out so no sooner had I faxed the third
out and the phone started ringing and in those days we had an old fashioned phone system where you could
see a number of little pegs that would light up for an incoming line and I think that there
were as many as six incoming lines so you could look at a single phone and see six of these
clear pegs and a peg would be lit depending upon what the incoming number was and at first you know
through the third fax there was one of these little pegs that lit up so I answered it
while I was continuing to fax and it was newsweek or something and they wanted some pithy quotes
about the life of Linus Pond and it wasn't difficult for me but it really took some effort to hold
myself together to give them cogent statements about Linus Pond because I was feeling really sad
and I was manically trying to fax all these obituaries out and before long every light was lit
and blinking and it was the New York Times it was CBS it was everybody under the Sunworn statements
so I spent the better part of that early evening there responding to all these all these phone
calls for more information and then the next day of course everybody at the Institute knew that Linus Pond
had died and there was a lot of grief people were crying and it was it was a really difficult time for
everybody in terms of being the footing of being instituted so like that point where how do character
actually mean the namesake of the instituted just died and what is what the outlook for the
organization at that point yeah we had of course in the board of trustees meetings which we had
very regularly by the way and then we had reports that went out to the board every month
because there were so many problems and we wanted everything to be done as perfectly as possible
so I would write a report to the board of trustees every month and send it off to all of them by
facts and that would cover all the personal issues financial issues I would have the account and
give us a status of our bank accounts investments and so forth so that everybody knew all the
time exactly where we were and of course we took very seriously the problem of leaving the building
in Palo Alto and Linus Pond had expressed the desire I think his his first priority was for the
Institute to remain independent because I thought I think he felt that we could probably
be unswade by mainstream medicine or mainstream science if we retained independence we could be
more a conoclastic and more of a maverick organization but absent that he completely supported the idea
of integrating into an appropriate university with academic activities that would resonate
with the Institute's mission so who was supportive of that but he died before the discussions
were the Oregon State University had really matured we had lots of people coming to the Institute
presenting different options to us ideas about you know what they would do in the Institute should
we transfer funds to them and the name and so on and so forth and there was one fellow who was a
relocation specialist who had contacted me who had a lot of contacts with universities around the
country and thanks to his good graces we initiated discussions with university administrators in
Wisconsin and Boston University at Oklahoma and a lot of different places to find out if there was any
interest in the Linus Pond Institute so all those conversations and to be honest with you
as so many things were happening in that short period of time I can't really place everything
chronologically but polling was certainly aware of the desire that the board had to keep the
Institute going and say working tribute to his ideas in North America and the medicine and there
were different options being discussed one for instance was I think this was brought up by one of
our trustees maybe what we should do is just closing Institute down liquidate everything and take
that money and establish a chair in Linus Pond's name at Caltech or Stanford or someplace like
that that would be most meaningful to Linus Pond so those there were lots of different possibilities
that were that were pretty seriously discussed at those days but financially you had a couple
pretty big gifts that came and then basically kept you about water for a little while that's right
and that's right and that really improved the probability of securing the interest of an academic
institution too because one problem that we confronted with lots of universities was that they just
didn't have a lot of vacant space they can space doesn't exist in the University environment I mean
it's subsumed by departments or units right away so there wasn't a lot of existing space
in any of the universities that we talked with where we could just waltz right in and make ourselves
at home and people have different impressions of the of the reputation of the Institute so you know
there's there are always people that believe that Pauling was flaky with the Vitamin C and
North Molecular Medicine and there were probably institutions that shared that attitude as well so
we recognized that any institution who was looking to gain the Linus Pond Institute would also be gaining perhaps
a little bit of a risk as well and the litigation you know had been covered in the papers so
you know it was a difficult time there was no question that it wasn't a you know a perfect
organization with a stellar medical scientific record that was coming in with no stains you know
there were some problems image problems perhaps so we were concerned that that would be
make it very difficult for people to be you know to warmly receive the Institute so the money
really improved the probability because when you can bring money while suddenly
University of Administrators can see much more potential if you're bringing some money with you
okay who was wrong at the next time thanks to you